the number of arrests that the U.S
Southern border has never been higher
U.S border Patrol recorded 2.4 million
migrant Encounters in the last fiscal
year
Pedro was one of them he says he crossed
through seven countries to get from
Venezuela to the United States the main
reason
why
I had to go
it's because I was a scare Pedro was
among 150 000 Venezuelans allowed to
remain in the country to file for Asylum
most of those Asylum Seekers wait near
the border to be processed but recently
Governors from republican-led border
states have been putting migrants like
him on buses and sending them to
democratic-led cities in protest of
federal immigration policies
with a record number of migrants
Crossing into the United States and
arriving in cities like New York by the
busload the government has promised to
allow 24
000 Venezuelans to remain in the country
and work on humanitarian grounds but
they have to apply before they get here
and thanks to a deal with Mexico those
who enter the country illegally going
forward will be deported without a
chance to file for Asylum under a law
enacted during the pandemic President
Joe Biden has blamed the latest increase
in border crossings on a handful of
autocratic countries including Venezuela
we have a process in place to manage
migrants of the Border we're working to
make sure it's safe and orderly and
Humane Republican officials should not
interfere with that process by waging a
political these political stunts
but it's not just Venezuelans being
deported since the administration came
into office something like 30 000 people
have been deported to Haiti at a time
where the country is going through a
very extraordinary challenges migrant
Advocates say the U.S policy is inhumane
he's using Trump Arab policies to pretty
much shut down our border in a really
horrific way where you're stopping
people who desperately need support from
being able to come in as for those
already in the country like Pedro they
have one year to apply for asylum in the
current political climate he worries his
future here is anything but certain
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New York